Continuing
in the chapter
of patience
of the illustrious
and most important of books,
authored by
Muhamad.
Were we
[Silence]
the final verse that he mentions
as
laying the foundations
for the rest of the narrations that are
going to be mentioned in this chapter
is the statement of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala
found in verse number 31 of surah
[Arabic recitation]
also known as
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says that
which translates to and indeed verily
surely we are going to test you all
so as to and we will test you until We
know and see who of you is striving
and who of you are patient.
What does this mean? We're going to test
you until we know.
for
[Silence]
the question here that you know presents
itself is it's a curious choice of
words. Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala is
saying we are going to test you all with
tribulations, with crises, with
difficulties, with ease, with pleasure,
with pain
until
we see, until we know who of you is
striving
and who of you is truly patient. So what
does that mean? Does Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala not know who of us is of such
character
already?
The answer is that knowledge here in
this context is two types in the Quran.
You have knowledge of Allah
subhanahuaala
which is
Allah subhanahu waala is infinite
timeless knowledge
before he created as he created after he
created after he does away with the
creation he subhanahu wa ta'ala knew all
that was and knows all that is and all
that will be and knows all that would be
had things been. Subhanahu wa ta'ala.
This is how Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
refers to this knowledge when he refers
to writing in the preserved tablet. when
he refers to
his
writing of all of the decree of what
is to be until the day of judgment.
So this here is the knowledge of the
preserved tablet. However, knowledge of
what was and is and will be is not the
same as knowledge of something that
happened. And that is why the companions
such as Abbas when they speak about
these verses.
So we will test you until we see who of
you. Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala already
knows. However, he has not seen it yet.
And him seeing something and hearing
something is what he rewards for. He
does not reward a human being or punish
a human being based on what he knows
will happen.
He rewards or punishes based on what he
sees or hears happen. Subhanahu wa
ta'ala. So Abbas he as
and others mention that knowledge here
what is meant by it is knowledge of what
has already happened. Knowledge of what
has happened.
meaning seeing when Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala sees something happen then he
rewards then he punishes subhanahu wa
ta'ala accordingly
this is an important point because Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala's knowledge his
infinite
timeless knowledge is not what we are
rewarded or punished for rather it is
his knowledge of us doing something
something that is in the past that is
what we are rewarded or punished for.
That's number one. Number two, when
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala mentions
himself here, he mentions this along
with the royal we. He doesn't say till I
see. He says we. Who is we? here in this
type of context it is Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala the angels of punishment the
angels of reward the angels of paradise
the angels of the hellfire the angels
that write the deeds they are all going
to see what the human being does
including the believers including the
disbelievers including the human being
himself
he sees of himself
what is and So Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
knows who of us is truly striving and
who of us is patient. May Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala make us all of those
who are truly striving and truly
patient. He knows that we don't know
that. And until we know this and until
he sees this, we cannot be we cannot be
rewarded or punished for that. This also
tells us, this verse also tells us, and
there's others it, the reason why
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tests us, the
reason we have difficulty in our lives.
Sometimes people ask a very silly
question. They say things like, "If
Allah wants us to be good, why didn't he
just create us good?" Well, then what
did we earn in doing that? What is what
is majestic or great about a creation
that doesn't earn its rank? What's
what's so special about that? Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us
he says subhanahua we have not created
the heavens and the earth out of sport
as an amusement to play. We're not
playing here. If we wanted
to observe a sport or some kind of
entertainment, we would have done this
with other creatures that are closest to
us. Meaning the highest ranking of
angels. If Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
only wanted to observe
and be entertained to Allah, he
subhanahua is above being benefited by
his creation. But hypothetically
speaking,
if sport was the purpose of the
creation, there are much better
creatures than you and I for such
entertainment. Look at the misery that
human beings put each other through.
Look at the spilled blood. Look at the
horrors and terrors that creep and roam
the earth. This is not any kind of
entertainment but for the sadistic. No,
the purpose of this creation is not only
for us to become better but for us to
earn, for us to grow. He creates a
creation that is weak and small and
helpless and he gives it its tools and
it builds itself up through his help
subhanahu wa ta'ala. This is the closest
a human being or any creation can be to
independence as possible. And so the
reason why Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
creates us in a deficit is in order for
us to earn to earn through Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala otherwise what's the
point of creating us automatically
creating us perfect creating us in
the way that we should strive for
there's no growth there there's no
earning we don't learn anything by that
and that is the whole point of our
existence. Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
says
he says successful are those who
who grow and purify their souls. A zak
in the Arabic language
means two things sim at the same time.
Purity and growth
and
the one who is successful is the one who
grows his spirit and purifies his
spirit. How do we do that? Through
revelation and through hardship. That's
the way we grow. We do that through
knowledge and implementation.
That's why Allah gives us examples in
the Quran always with fire and water
with revelation and hardship. They go
hand in hand. The human being grows.
Subhanahu
Sai Wasam.